dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here
3d printing is a rapidly progressing
research field one can create colorful
patterns that we call textures on
different figures with computational
hydrographic printing just to name one
of many recent dimensions we can 3d
print teeth action figures prosthetics
you name it ever thought of how cool it
would be to design robots on your
computer digitally and simply printing
them scientists at Disney research had
just made this dream come true I fondly
remember my time working at Disney
research where robots like these were
walking about I remember a specific guy
that well wasn't really kind and waved
at me
it has blocked the path to one of the
labs I have to enter it might have been
one of these guys in this project
Disney research has an incredible
atmosphere with so many talented people
it's an absolutely amazing place so in
order to get a robot from A to B one has
to specify scientific attributes like
trajectories and angular velocities but
people don't really think in angular
velocities they think in intuitive
actions like moving forward sideways or
even the style of a desired movement
specifying these things instead would be
much more useful that sounds great and
all but this is a quite difficult task
if one specifies a high level action
like walking sideways then the algorithm
has to find out what body parts to move
how which motors should be turned on and
when which joins to turn where is the
center of pressure the center of mass
and many other factors have to be taken
into consideration this technique offers
a really slick solution to this where we
don't just get a good result but we can
also have our say on what should the
order of steps be and even more our
stylistic suggestions are taken into
consideration
one can also change the design of the
robot for instance different shapes
motor positions and joints can be
specified the author's ran a simulation
for these designs and constraints and
found them to be in good agreement with
reality this means that whatever you
design digitally can be 3d printed with
off-the-shelf parts and brought to life
just as you see them on the screen the
Technic supports an arbitrary number of
legs and is robust to a number of
different robot designs amazing is as
good of a world as I can find the kids
of the future will be absolutely spoiled
with their toys that's for sure and I'm
perfectly convinced that there will be
many other applications and these guys
will help us solve problems that are
currently absolutely inconceivable for
us thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time